et nous sommes avec douglas yates
professeur de droit spécialiste en
sciences politiques américaines bonjour
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bernie sanders a donc écrasé
la concurrence dans les vallées il
s'installe en tête de ces primaires
démocrates est ce que c'est une surprise
oui c'est une très bon début pour lui
qui était le candidat favori dans le
dernier élections on a tous les soupçons
qui le relie à gagner on tricher avec
les super candidate est donc bernie à
son dû maintenant dans les trois
premières primaires mais on a des doutes
pour supporter ou c'est justement ce ce
super cuisez le lundi 3 mars
quatorze états américains vont voter en
même temps dan sanders est quand même
bien placé il a promis la victoire quel
est votre pronostic
oui ok dernier et bienne connu toutes
les candidates c'est lui qui était
présent depuis quatre ans et une
campagne permanente toute leur sont
devenus récemment joe boyd et même après
bernie était devenu le candidat de
cendres donc bernier est une objets
connus il a gagné 2-1 1-3 primaire
qu'ils ont des petites voix mais les
grandes voix s'achète et mike bloomberg
probablement va être le candidat
surprise peut être le premier parce
qu'il a investi 600 millions de dollars
s'achète beaucoup d des publicités dans
le super bowl par exemple et aussi dans
les grandes et at il y a des gens qui
préfèrent une candidate centriste
bloomberg et centristes comme candidate
vraie gauche d'un et sanders
on dit qu'il doit en grande partie son
succès à l'électorat latino aux
minorités à la jeunesse très jeune très
généralement qu'est-ce qui leur promet
dans son programme ou est d'abord le
le soutiennent de leur santé à ce qu aux
etats unis les catastrophes c'est le
système de médecine système de santé
public donc d'abord beaucoup de gens de
se voit dans un système où ils sont
donnés le chances de soigner leur enfant
leur femme leur le propre corps mais
aussi permis en promesse d'une
révolution et pour toutes les minorités
raciales aux états unis se prononce
vêtements d'une changement de
l'oppression raciale et un même si ce
dernier semble blanche
il faut se souvenir que meunier juif et
donc minorités opprimées les juifs ont
la capacité de parler avec les autres
minorités comme bernie a bien montré
dont il a soutenu très fortement les
hispaniques
parce que c'est une voix qui compte dans
les élections mais le problème pour les
démocrates c'est que les minorités
raciales ne vote pas dans le même temps
que les blanches et où là où bernie peur
de les voir c'est plutôt parmi les
populations qui vaut plus souvent bernie
sanders ya soixante dix huit ont aidé
talonné de près par pete beauty djedj 38
ans c'est une des raisons aussi pour
lesquelles on voyait en ce petit nouveau
l'avenir du parti démocrate et pourtant
il est jusque-là devancé par bernie
sanders colombe expliqué ouais ok petit
budget et elle surprise mais en avoir
souvent dans les élections
présidentielles en candidate qui
viennent de nulle part t1 à penser aux
peut-être ces petits bouts des jays
mais berne et est très bien ancré dans
une campagne de fonde son se soutiennent
financière vient des petites gens il y a
plein des gens qui aussi fils quentin
dans une rue porte à porte
pendant que pitt comme nouveaux arrivés
n'a pas le même poids institutionnel
dans toutes les étapes et en voir
voir son faiblesse en super tuesday on a
plein de gens dans le parti démocratique
qui sont idéologiquement avec bernie
kibboutz djedj c'est plutôt au centre
hélas le centre s'est occupée par joe
biden et maintenant par michael
bloomberg
donc est ce que ça veut dire que dans
les prochaines semaines et notamment le
lors du super tuesday to teach peut
s'effondrer
oui à ce que michael bloomberg est là et
michael bloomberg a des milliards de
dollars et ce sera très difficile pour
tous budgets de se présenter dans toutes
les étapes et l'argent va jouer un grand
rôle
est-ce que bernie sanders selon vous
peut battre donald trump lors de la gdc
l'américain lone ranger tous ses jetons
les sondages le montrent mais ils
peuvent battre dans le bois populaire le
problème avec les élections s'il ne
touche pas le bases de données ou tram
et à cause des distorsions de
proportionnalité dans notre système de
collège électoral
c'est très difficile pour bernice en 2
de prendre les voix de dans nos trente
donc tout ce jour dans les indépendantes
au centre et les femmes alors est-ce que
l'espoir de voir une femme le néo
démocrate à la présidentielle américaine
ce qu'elle ait abandonné on a beaucoup
parlé avant le début de ces primaires
démocrates d'elizabeth warren un un
sentiment qu'elle a un peu laissé de
côté aujourd'hui oui oui elle était les
voix de gauche de lyss be one avec sa
promesse de taxer les riches et donnés
le santé publique à tous
s'occupe par les campagnes de bernis 1 2
et à sa droite
les gens qui sont plus raisonnables sont
un milliardaire et jobwings est un
ancien vice président le triste réalité
c'est que une femme même madame claude
béchard qui a des qualités
les vraies qualités dans le midwest ne
peuvent pas gagner parce que tout le
monde prend c'est maintenant il faut
gagner il faut battre dans notre âme
et oui c'est triste mais ils vont
abandonner
l'aspect féministe de cette élection
merci beaucoup d'être venu répondre à
nos questions douglas y être professeur
de droit spécialiste en sciences
politiques américaines